OK. I think we're live.
OK. Yes.
The screen was blocked out
for a second, but.
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
This is February 5th. 20, 21.
And we are here in Model Stream 4.0
with Ryan Smith and Christopher White.
I'm Daniel Freedman.
I'm a post-doctoral researcher
in California and a participant
in active inference lab.
Maybe the two of you can just briefly
reintroduce yourself.
Yes. For anybody who hasn't
been watching the previous sessions,
I'm Brian Smith.
I'm an investigator
at the Laureate Institute
for Brain Research in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
Hi. I'm Christopher Wyatt.
I'm a Ph.D.
student at the MRC Cognition Brain
Sciences Unit in Cambridge, England.
Awesome.
Well, we are here today in part four,
which will be the last section
on this paper, hopefully
not the last time
we get to speak together on any extreme,
but it's part four of four on this paper,
a step by step
tutorial on active inference
and its application to empirical data.
You can find a link to the most
updated version of that resource
in the video descriptions.
And as far as points of process,
if you have any questions or comments
or thoughts during the live stream,
you can type it into the live chat
and we'll address it
when the time is right.
If you have questions arising after this
live stream or you're watching it
after it's occurred,
feel free to leave a comment and we'll
try to address it in future sessions
because the model stream never ends.
So to learn and participate
and learn about how to participate,
go to active inference dot
org that's where you'll find
more information on active inference.
So today in our fourth session,
it's going to be pretty exciting
because we've covered a lot
of the groundwork.
And Daniel E for it, right? Yeah.
We're not hearing anything. Daniel. Oh.
Give me one sec.
OK, do you hear me now?
No. Yeah, you froze.
All right.
Give me a second.
It's all good.
This is how it happens
sometimes when live streaming.
Let me go back to the events,
and I will rejoin the events
All right.
Cool.
Waiting. This is just how it is.
Welcome to live streaming, everyone.
Cool.
Look at that ghost. Daniel Freedman.
He can be kicked out.
You're really quiet again.
OK, ok. OK.
Yes, due to do device settings
OK. Yes.
Thanks Microsoft's teams
for facilitating these conversations.
It's still live and happening
it's just a little,
little hiccup with teams that now
we've gotten that out of the way.
So it's fixed.
But they right in.
I don't know if this other person
can be kicked out, but take it away.
We're all good, though. Thank you.
OK, maybe
that one or.
The ghost of Daniel's past.
It's OK.
It will auto drop them like after you
shared on share but it's all chill, ok?
OK. Perfect. OK.
I thought that worked.
OK, so we are still.
We are still alive and going.
Yep. OK,
All right.
So question
just start or there anything else?
You are kind of
in the middle saying something.
Just if we could start with some recap
for those who probably have seen
the first three sessions, just
where did we get to as of today?
And then where does
that take us into the future?
OK. So yeah, just as a quick recap,
Daniel said the whole purpose
of this tutorial
that we put out
was to try to make methods for actually
building active inference models
and applying them to experimental data.
We want
to try to make those methods
more accessible to a broader audience
because up until now, it's been fairly
difficult to find sort of clear
resources for beginners
to start learning these sorts of methods.
And so the whole kind of the whole
point of what we've covered
so far is kind of been building
to this section
if the focus again is going to be about
being able to actually use these models
for experiments.
So obviously the earlier sections
could be useful on their own
if you want to do simulation work
and there's lots of papers
reporting simulation work.
But in terms of then applying the models
and simulation work that you do to
to actual experiments
to actually fit it to
task behavior with participants
and, you know, predict things
about like neural responses and MRI
studies and all that kind of stuff,
then it all kind of boils down to what
we'll talk about today.
So in earlier sections, we kind of
covered the basics of active inference.
You know what for energy,
what variational for energy
is what expected for energy is
what the motivation is for doing active
inference, what the potential benefits
are over traditional reinforcement
learning models,
you know, things, things like things like
that is kind of the nuts and bolts.
And then we covered how to build active
inference,
partially observable
markup decision process models.
And as an example, we built a
simple kind of explore
exploit model, which I will or exploit.
What test model should I say,
as a as a just kind of a concrete example
of how you would build a model.
And we showed some
simulations both for perception
and decision making and for learning
with that model.
And so and then we also kind of
took a took a break from that.
We're going to return to that now.
But we also took a break from that
a little bit to cover
hierarchical models
and the neural process theory
but now we're going to come back
to using the Explore Exploit task model
because it's
simpler and more straightforward in terms
of what you do with participant behavior
and and how you fit it.
So so all that, like I said, is
building up to using the task model
we built as an example
for setting it to data.
So, Christopher.
I don't know that. Yeah.
Great summary.
Christopher,
what would be your perspective
or what was something
that stood out to you.
From the previous sessions? Yep.
Because you're you're so both deep
in the game and actually producing
this artifact that it's been fun for us
and for the audience just to be
kind of talking through it because it
so what, what does it leave upon somebody
who's been involved in the generation
of this artifact now to be talking.
About
interesting question, I suppose, and
I thought I think it has made
and I'm just so this is kind of
in the context I have I started my PhD
four months ago, so this is all kind of
in the context of figuring out
not just how to build these models
kind of for myself
or sorry how to teach other people
how to build these models rather but
actually how to build these models myself
and apply my own research questions
and so I actually have never fitted them
to all of the stuff that I've done
so far as been theory, essentially
just I've done a lot of simulation work,
but no
I don't think so.
I don't know.
I think that's actually the frontier
in active inference at the moment
is actually figuring out
how to get these models to hit the road.
And there's a really one, one really
tricky thing is most of the people
who work on active inference
in a real way and your images.
So for I for example,
I mean in your engine department,
I know, Ryan, you're working your imaging
as well.
It's actually
challenging to test these models
in the domain of neuro imaging.
Your imaging is really hard, actually.
I think many of the clearest predictions
actually in terms of the
your process theory are actually things
that you could test really quite easily
with optogenetics, not optogenetics
or anything like that's easy.
But say predictions about micro
circuitry in PFC,
which active inference certainly makes
can very much
be tested easily in a rodent model.
But it's really difficult
to test it in a human.
And so I think
the point
that I'm trying to in a rather
rambling way get to is
I think we need to think
very deeply about when we build models
about what it actually is
that we're trying to solve.
Do we just want a directional hypothesis,
in which case you don't necessarily
need to fit these things to data?
You're just saying as the
it will be bigger than day,
which is still better
than most psychology.
Let's let's be honest
yeah.
It's really interesting.
The neuroimaging case has a few specific
difficulties, massive amounts of data
in a system
that has massively complex internal
and external dynamics like the brain.
And you're making a ton of data
with a very complex error profile.
And in the SPM textbook it's
chapters and chapters of normalization
and re warping
and all these different kinds of ways
to deal with these very complex
data sets.
And now we've almost built out
that framework.
And now,
just like you said, where it's hitting
the road is in being applied
to empirical data.
And it's a little bit of a surprise.
It, at least to me and probably others,
that maybe neural imaging although that's
the home of SPM we're seeing,
it applies to systems beyond neuro
imaging and even there's other systems
that help inform our neuroimaging quest.
So pretty interesting stuff
OK. So should we just get started then?
It sounds good
and anyone in the live chat
just drop a question
and we'll get to them.
Thanks a lot.
OK, so one
brief thing that I did want to mention
is that a couple of times ago
we we talked about we covered learning,
but since then just wanted
to let people know
we actually caught a little a small error
in the learning section
in the previous version
that we've now corrected.
And it has to do with the way
that you calculate the
the novelty term and expected free energy
that gets added to
you gets added to expected free energy
when you're doing learning.
So that's what drives the parameter
exploration term expected for energy.
It basically drives an agent to seek out
policies that will tell it more about,
in this case, what the matrix looks like.
So tell us more about
what the relationship is between states
and observations.
And there's equivalent terms
that could be added
if you're trying to learn
transition beliefs or other matrices
and vectors in the model.
But so now just to kind of make
that clear,
we actually have added
two different additional work examples of
how of how to calculate
the the novelty term,
just to make sure that's clear.
So if anybody doesn't happen
to have the kind of most updated version
and you're interested
in kind of knowing the kind
of rigorous details
about how learning works
in the in the formalism, then, you know,
it might be helpful
to download the updated version
so that you can have
additional work examples to
to get a better sense about that works.
So I just wanted to make that clear.
Like I said, it wasn't
it's not like a big error,
but it's a small error
that if you were to read
it it could be confusing.
So I just wanted to make
what I wanted
to highlight that for people.
But today, like I mentioned,
the focus is going to be on
actually building task models.
So and applying them to data.
And there's actually,
you know, it's probably, you know, this
doesn't this isn't necessarily
like the only way you could break it up.
But I've broken this up
into kind of six steps that are probably
a good kind of heuristic,
you know, roadmap or whatever
you want to call it
for doing this kind of work.
So the first thing is
that you have to have a task
and you have to have participants perform
that task.
And the second thing is
you have to build one
or more models of that task
so one or more models
in this case partially observable
markup decision process models
in the act of inference formulation
that can refer duse or generate
simulated behavior for that task.
And so once you do that,
then the next thing you need to do is
you need to find somehow find
parameter values in each of those models
that you construct constructs
that can best reproduce
each participant's behavior
so for instance, under one model,
you might find
that the first participant,
the model can reproduce
the first participant's behavior,
the best if it has a particular,
say, value
for how much they want the reward.
So for instance, like the value of the
or that you think about it as a precision
of the preference distribution.
Or you might find that
for another participant
you need a lower value for that
to reproduce their behavior.
Well,
and but they need
something like a higher learning rate
or a lower action precision value, right?
There's all these different parameters
in these models we've been covering
and different values
for those parameters are going to
be better
different parameter value combinations.
And these model is going to be better
at reproducing one person's behavior
versus another on the task.
And so what that requires is having
some kind of estimation algorithm,
something that basically searches
through in some way
different combinations of parameters
and checks how well it reproduces
a given participants behavior.
And so and so, like I said,
those called parameter estimation
algorithms and there's a few
there's several different
types that you can use.
I'll briefly mention a few
and then we'll go into detail on
the one
that is probably most consistent with
the general kind
of theme of active inference models,
which is
a scheme called Variational Bayes.
So once you've found for each model
the parameter values that best describe
each participant, then you want to know,
OK, well which of those models
is the best model?
And so in that case,
you need some kind of way of comparing
how well each model on average
can reproduce the behavior
of the whole group of your participants.
So each model is going to have their best
fit parameters for each participant,
but still the best fit parameters
for one model might still do a better job
than the best fit parameters
for another model.
And again, we'll go into this
and then once you've identified
what the the best model is
then and this
is something that might not be obvious,
but it's really important is
you have to somehow confirm
that the parameters in the best model
are recoverable.
So you can hear the talk about this
as whether the model is identifiable
or the parameters of the model
are recoverable.
And that's something that again,
I'll expand on.
But but the basic idea is or 11
kind of simple way to think about it is
what if it's the case that two different
combinations of parameter values
are equally good
at reproducing or explaining
a given participant's behavior?
If that were the case,
then there isn't any unique
combination of parameter values.
That is kind of the best set
of parameter values.
And what that means is that
you could take
one set of parameter
values, generate behavior with it.
But when you ran estimation on that,
you could get
a very different set
of parameter estimates.
And if that's the case,
then the parameter estimates
that you're actually getting
for that model for a participant
aren't necessarily a reliable or uniquely
best description
and so that means that parameters
aren't recoverable or there's no kind of
uniquely best set of parameters
under that model.
So you need to do that to make sure
that's true for the winning model.
And if it's not, then you might move down
to, say, the second best model
and see if that's the case.
All right.
So you want to find the best
fitting model.
Ideally,
you want to find the best fitting model
that is also clearly recoverable,
that has clearly recoverable parameters
and finally, once you have identified
the winning recoverable model
and you have this set of parameter
estimates that describe each person.
So these are individual
different variables, right?
One person has higher action precision
and then another one person
has a more precise
preference distribution than another.
And at this point,
you can take these up to the group level
and you can say, OK,
you know, for instance,
does a health group have different
parameter values on average
than, say, a group with depression
or a group with anxiety?
Or you can say, you know, do
parameter values
predict something on a continuous,
you know, in a continuous way?
Right.
Maybe higher anxiety levels are
associated with lower action precision
or something like that.
And so I'll show you guys examples
of this kind of thing as well.
So first, and
you know, we've kind of already
covered this in previous sessions
or just examples of it,
but there are lots of different
kinds of tasks that you can model,
which is kind of a nice perk of active
inference models,
is that they're not just about decision
making as a main component.
You can also use them to model
kind of simple perceptual tasks.
So Christopher, in a previous session,
showed how you could build a model
of a simple perceptual oddball
or a local global task,
which is almost entirely
about perception.
You won't get necessarily interesting
individual differences
in behavior in these tasks,
but you can show differences in, say,
simulated event related
potentials in EEG studies.
And in principle,
you could fit the ear piece
to find the best parameters for a person.
But you can also do
inferential or inferential
or prospective decision making tasks
like where you plan for the future
and make a decision
based on what you expect
future outcomes to be,
which is the kind of thing
kind of like
what I'll be showing you
or with the Explore Exploit task.
But the Explore Exploit task
that we'll be showing is is kind of
very similar to a standard
kind of reinforcement learning task.
It just requires that you seek out
information before you can really know
or even learn
what the right reward values are.
And then lastly,
you could combine this with neuroimaging
in the context of predictions
from the neural processing area,
which is what we've talked about
and what we covered in relation
to the hierarchical model that
Christopher covered
so I should say
that this
is kind of a fairly new emerging field.
And so there's not that many papers,
empirical papers
that do this kind of thing.
You know, it's
something that my lab has kind of been
trying to make more common practice
which is again, part of the motivation
for this tutorial is so that
a larger number of researchers
can do this kind of thing.
But so you know,
I mainly work in computational psychiatry
and so, you know,
if this has been used to show, say,
for instance, less, less precise lower
action, precision and substance
use disorder
and also slower learning rates
for negative outcomes
and substance use disorder,
you know, we've shown things like that.
Greater decision
uncertainty is associated with
people with depression,
anxiety and substance use
in the context of approach,
avoidance, conflict tasks.
And most recently,
we also use kind of a simpler
Bayesian perception
version of an active inference
to show differences in the sensory
precision and in an intercept of context.
So for instance, when people
how, how
precisely or accurately people
perceive their own heartbeats,
an interesting differences there
between, again, clinical and multiple
clinical groups and healthy participants.
And then lastly, and you know,
one of the first papers using this
kind of approach was actually Phillips
quarterbacks paper where they looked at
predictions about midbrain,
midbrain, dopaminergic responses
and changes
in the expected free energy perception
term that we had talked
about in previous sessions.
And I was able to show nice relationships
between these expected
precision updates and and what
and neural responses using if MRI
in a region of the midbrain
that is known to be rich
in dopamine neurons.
So this is just kind of
these are recent examples. But,
you know, we're hoping other researchers
can and can, you know, build on.
On that neuro slide.
These examples.
We're seeing a couple of examples
of different technologies like MRI.
But we also heard it goes beyond
neuroimaging, the scope of these methods.
And we're also seeing a couple
of biological questions or conditions
related to your clinical experience.
Let me compliment those two
axes of variation with the methods
in the biological question
with this algorithmic dimension.
And there's a question in the chat
that says what kinds of tasks
reflect the relationship
between dynamic programing
and active inference, for example, Belman
Optimal State Action Policies.
Thanks for the elaboration.
So how do we connect
some of these biological
and methodological uses
and axes of variation
to some of the algorithmic questions
about optimization, dynamic programing?
So yes, I mean, that's a great question.
We actually have a recent preprint
that lands to Costas first author on
where he
was able to come up with some proofs
to show
when active inference is
and is not Belmont optimal.
And in terms of one,
the the conclusion was in terms
of one step policies act of inference
is Belmont optimal in the context where
the precision of the preference
distribution is maximal,
it's maximally precise over
whatever the reward outcome is
active inference models
in the kind of simple
idea appeal MVP scheme
we've been talking about here
they're not Belmont optimal
or they're not guaranteed to be
in the context of multistep
so like deep temporal qualities
but whereas the more recent
sophisticated act of inference
algorithms are Belmont
optimal for deep policies
because they more or less correspond
to backward induction.
So that's
that's the probably shortest
answer I could give to that.
Christopher, did you
have something to add there?
Uh, no,
I yeah, I was just going to point to
the landslide, the cost of paper grade.
I posted the cost of papers
that I think are relevant in the chat.
So thanks for that question.
And continue.
OK, so just to be clear,
this is a very specific paper
that, you know, Lance
and I and, and a few other people
put out as a preprint
just a couple of months ago.
So so I'm talking about one particular
paper
of, of Lance's.
So I mean,
I can certainly that point that
that specific one out and so people know
which one I'm talking about.
The relationship between dynamic
programing and active inference
to the discrete finite horizon case with.
Yeah.
That's the one.
To caster power friction and Smith.
Yep. OK, cool.
All right.
So hopefully that helps
OK, so now I'll kind of be going through
each of the,
the steps here that I was talking about
kind of one by one, right,
with our explore exploit test example.
So first step one is you have to have
participants perform a task, right?
So in this case and I should say for
some of this, it's really going
to be assumed that people were following
along with previous sessions at the time
constraints just really don't allow us
to cover all the background and
so that somebody could watch this one
without having seen
the other ones and fully follow
everything I'll be talking about.
So just just to make that clear,
if anything is kind of confusing
then the previous sessions
are kind of necessary.
We walk through the matrices and some of
the degrees of freedom in this set up.
So I think it should be good
to check out the other videos if
you haven't already.
But but, you know, as a brief
kind of refresher about the task
that we're talking about,
the on each trial, the agent starts
in a start state and then it can either
directly choose one of two slot machines
and if they're right, they'll win $4.
But if they're wrong, they'll 10
and they start out not knowing,
you know, like just flat prior over
whether the left or the right one is
whether it's the context
in which the left or the right
one is more likely to win.
So it's just 5050.
So it's pretty risky
to just pick one right away,
at least before you've learned
if one of them is actually more likely
if the context in which one is more
likely to win is more common.
So instead,
the other thing that the agent can do
is they can choose to get a hint
and the hint will tell them which
whether it's a context
in which the left bandit is the one
that is more likely to win
and when it's the right one
and in each of the contacts in the left
in the context where the left one's
better, it will payout 80% of the time
whereas in the context of the right one,
the right one will pay out
80% of the time.
But the catch is
if you choose to take the hint,
then you'll only win $2
if you get the right one afterwards.
So this trades off this kind of reward
seeking and information seeking,
where if you seek information
first, you're more likely to win.
But if you choose first right away,
then you'll get a higher reward
if you're right.
So it specifically trades
off reward and uncertainty
and this is where a lot of
this is not going to make sense
unless you've seen the previous sessions,
is that the second thing is
you have to build one
or more models of the task
we just talked about.
In our example, we'll use two different
variants of the model one where
we're just going to fit
the risk seeking parameter
and an action precision parameter
and a second model where we also assume
that the agent has a learning rate
or that there are differences
in learning right.
So for those that don't remember,
the risk
seeking parameter just corresponds
to the magnitude of this RC value.
So at this says is at time
two, if the agent observes
a win, Cicero's a win,
then the value of that win will be Rs
and if they instead wait and choose
the hint, they'll continue
to observe this start thing at time,
two at a time, three.
If they win, then the value they will win
will be
this Rs value divided by two.
So so whatever Rs ends up
being the win at the third time point,
if they take the hint is half of that.
I'm so going to be setting
for each person what that RS value is,
which again stands for risk seeking,
which would be clear to anyone
who's watched the previous sessions,
because the higher this value is, the
the less exploratory drive
the agent will have
and that means that they'll be
more likely to take the risk and just
choose one of the slot machines randomly
as opposed to taking the hint first
to be more confident in which ones right.
So the second parameter
is this action precision parameter alpha.
And all this basically says
is the precision or the probability
of selecting some action
given an alpha value corresponds to this.
So our corresponds
to whatever the probability
is of an action, given the given a policy
scaled by this alpha thing
and then soft max to become a
just a proper probability
distribution again.
So it just controls how more or less
it controls how precise
action selection
is given the choice of policy
and then finally in the model,
in the second model,
where we're also going to assume
an agent has a learning rate
other than just the optimal learning
rate of one,
then we're also going to be fitting
this thing
ETA here, which is the learning rate.
And this just says that your beliefs
about the probability of the context
being that
the left slot machine is better versus
at the right slot machine is better.
Just updates
based on your beliefs about whatever the
that state, whatever the winning state
was on the previous trial.
Again, four times step one.
So basically each trial,
whatever the posterior beliefs were over
states,
they the count for that just gets added
to whatever
the prior of our initial states was at.
That is at the next time point,
but it's scaled by this ETA thing.
So, you know, if ETA is one,
then it'll talk on account of one again
if if it knows with certainty
that it was in say like state one.
But if ETA is 0.7,
that only at a count of point
seven on each trial, given that
the posterior distribution was like 10
so so that's
the the basic set up
is we're going to fit either
just RC and Alpha
or we're going to fit both of those.
And ETA
and one note on that, Ryan,
I like the step to build one
or more models because we're thinking
about active inference
as like this process theory.
It's instrumental you know, the whole
instrumental ism versus realism question.
We're using it as an instrument,
and that means that
we're iterating over models
or relating our models
to each other in specific ways, like
make the simpler one and then make one
that just adds one more variable.
And then it's not like you're asking
what is the active inference model here?
It's here's the active inference
approach, and we're going to combine
our perspectives and make multiple models
and we'll be comparing models.
So the only limiting factor there is
how many models can
we think of at the beginning
and how wise can our model selection
process be?
So it's just really like a pluralistic
but pragmatic way to go about it
by saying construct one or more models
because then you're never going to fall
in the trap of thinking.
You're making the active inference model
because there isn't the model
of anything. Statistically,
they're just instruments.
So it's a really helpful perspective.
And so this isn't just a little
convenience to make one or more models.
It's something that reminds the scientist
or the modeler that they're actually
making one of many or infinite
possible ways to think about a situation.
Yeah, I mean, I mean, hopefully
you've really kind of
thought deeply about what the most
plausible models that are given current
theory and, you know, current, previous
or previous empirical research, right?
So I mean, they should be informed
by. Yes.
So you're just you're
trying to find the model that has the
highest evidence that the observations
or the behavior provides
the highest evidence for.
And yes,
it is always possible that there's
some other model that you haven't
thought of that would be better.
But, you know, if you have a model
that explains behavior really well
and it does
so better than any of the other ones
you can think of, then it's
kind of a good bet as at least giving you
interesting individual differences
to to again, bring up to our
group level analysis
so so OK, so,
you know,
to get kind of a little nitty gritty
in terms of the code and the MATLAB
structure, and everything, you know,
the kind of thing you need to do
is you first.
So you have a participant's
behavior, right?
Like it shows the hint
and then slot machine
one that shows the hint and then slot
machine two, OK,
now that just shows the slot machine
right away or slot machine two right away
and so forth.
And those have to be coded in
right to each trial.
And the MVP structure which which again
previous sessions will explain.
So the MVP structure in MATLAB
for each so each
each number
right inside these parentheses
here will be the trial
that you're talking about.
And the dot you hear is the,
the matrix that describe that
encodes
the actions that a participant took
now if we remember
so row one here corresponds to state
factor one, which is the context,
whether it left or right is better
and there is no action for that.
That's not something agent control.
It's just stable within a trial.
Which one it is.
So these just get ones
and there is no other possible action
for the second row, though.
So this is the state factor
that corresponded to action selection
to, you know, action to corresponded
to taking the hint and action
three corresponded to choosing left.
So if that was what a participant
did on trial, one
then you would have to feed in two
followed by three.
Right. They chose the hint
and then they chose left on that trial.
And so you just have to iterate
that over all the trials in the task
so one to end trials, whatever they did.
So that's MVP.
And in this case, like I said,
there are two actions or two columns
and there are two state factors
where only the rows
which are on the second one is control
so now p 00 is the observations.
So again, if you're familiar with the M,
the way we set up the model for this task
before, there are three different
outcome modalities, three different types
of observations you can get.
So the first observation modality,
what a hint or not.
So in this case, one is just you're kind
of still observing the start observation
if you observe two, that means you
get a hint that the left one is better.
And if you observe a three, that's
the hint that the right one is better.
So in this case, they got the observation
that the left one is better
when they tell
one to
one, because after they got the hint,
they just returned back to observing
kind of the initial observation
or the hint modality
whereas for the second modality
here, which is the wins losses
for the first two time steps,
they just observe
kind of the starting observation here
because they chose the hint
at the second time point.
So there was no win or loss.
And then at time point three,
they observed a win.
So winners encoded as a three in this
model, and two are losses encoded by two.
And then the final outcome
modality is just the agent
observing what it does.
So in this case,
this just says start it and start state
chose to take the
hint and then chose the left
shows start
it observed itself
choosing the choice of the left
slot machine.
So that's it.
So all you have to do when you're instead
of simulating behavior, you're actually
sitting where you're actually feeding
in participant behavior
to fit it to fit a model to it.
Then you just have to, you know, sort of
translate the behavior in the raw data
into a form like this
that matches the action and outcome
representations in the model.
And, and so that's it.
You first feed those in
and then once you've done that,
then you have to use
some kind of estimation algorithm,
which basically means
the thing is going to somehow repeat
simulating behavior in that model
until it finds a model that maximizes
the overlap between the probability
of choosing the participants
of the probability
of choosing actions and what the
participant actually chose.
Right.
So for instance, if it chose Hint
and then left band, it left slot
machine on trial one and it's
going to find a set of parameters
that apply across all trials
that maximize the probability
that the simulated agent
also would choose the hand, followed
by choosing the left slot machine.
So there are a number of different
estimation
algorithms that can be used.
You know, the the simplest possible
one is just something like a grid search.
So in this case,
say you just have two parameters
which this is just arbitrary
called alpha and beta.
You can kind of divide this up
into little grids, different combinations
of parameter values.
So for instance, like,
you know, parameter 0.24 alpha
and parameter value 34 beta.
And then you can just encode, for
example, what the probability
of the
model is given the participants actions.
Or that would be the posterior,
which I'll talk about
or just the probability
a part has been behavior given the model
and those parameter values.
I mean, so in this case, there's
this kind of clear nice result where
this value right here, something like 0.3
and for that
is maximally and uniquely
the best set of parameters
for reproducing
that participant's behavior.
And and in this case,
you're using something called
in this case you're using something
called maximum likelihood
so maximum likelihood estimation,
which just means again,
you're trying to find the model
and set a parameters for or which the
probability of the participants
behavior, given that model is highest,
which is a type of likelihood, right?
So you're trying to find the maximum
value for the likelihood,
which you're just in this
case, in code with this,
you know, redder colors
equals higher likelihood
of behavior.
Again, in the model,
you can also do something a little bit.
So to be clear, what we actually would
want right is is the inverse of this.
We would want the probability of a model
given participant behavior,
which is the posterior.
But when you're doing maximum likelihood
estimation, you're just assuming here
that you have essentially a flat prior
for what
the probability over models is.
So in this if that's the case,
then the probability of the model
given person
behavior is just proportional to
the likelihood.
But another thing you can do
is called on a posterior or map
estimates, which is the same thing,
except it doesn't assume
that you have a flat prior
or all right.
So if you just start out
with a prior expectation that one model
is better than another, then
you can incorporate that information into
into parameter estimation.
And this is kind of an example of this
where
you might find this distribution
in terms of just the likelihood right
the probability of data given the model
where a parameter combination
right around here would be best.
But then you might also have some reason
to have a prior
expectation that models down here.
Right, are actually more likely.
And so if you combine
those guys together,
you can get a posterior
that looks a little different right?
Like a something very similar, a set,
very similar model wins in this case.
But that's just because the behavior
that's driving the the likelihood here
is just already a really good fit.
So it kind of dominates
over over the influence of priors.
But that's not
always going to be the case.
So so those are two approaches.
And and again, you can
you can do them with a simple grid search
or you can do something.
So I should say that the grid search
kind of thing, it only really works
when you have a few parameters mean
you don't have very many.
And the reason is
because the more parameters
that you have, the higher dimensional
this parameter space becomes
and it just becomes it takes sort of
interactively long to do to search
through every possible combination
so what you do instead
is you use some kind of gradient
descent process.
Exactly
like the gradient descent on free energy
that we've been talking about
for how active inference models
arrive at posteriors over
states and posteriors or policies.
So there's a
really kind of interesting overlap
between the way that you estimate models,
the gradient descent and the way
that you actually the way that active
inference models update their beliefs
via gradient descent.
So in this case.
Or it's a very good point,
and I want to point out one similarity
in difference, because people may have
heard about these graded descent
algorithms for descriptive statistics
or for fitting descriptive models.
So that's from going again from the data
that's empirical to a descriptive model
or descriptive statistics
like regression coefficients.
And if it's a multivariable regression,
you might need to use
not just a grid search,
but that you can do a simple maximum
likelihood approach like a least squares
approach or something like that.
You need to use this kind of a complex,
multidimensional optimization
to get to that descriptive statistic.
And then there's this little twist
where actually in active inference,
we might be using
those computational techniques,
but we're estimating the parameters
of an underlying generative model
and then there's this nice little return
where actually the generative model is
implementing that as well.
Yeah.
So, so and so in this case,
you you absolutely need
some kind of prior value
because with gradient descent,
you're not exploring every combination.
What you're doing is you're starting
at some starting point,
which is just go to by a here
and then you're just like
when you're minimizing free energy
and in an active inference model,
you're searching neighboring values
and trying to find a value
that has a higher
likelihood or lower for energy.
And then you just kind of keep doing that
iteratively
until you find some value
that where the likelihood stops
getting bigger
or for energy stops getting smaller
and that then corresponds
to your best estimate
or your posterior posterior
estimate for the parameters
for a given participant. And
so when you're
doing this with when you're doing it
with gradient descent for for energy,
then that ends up corresponding
well to the actual approach
that we'll be talking about
or actually using in our example,
which is variational base.
So the variation base,
you do exactly this.
You set prior mean value and a prior
variance for each parameter,
and then you do a gradient descent
until you find a set of parameters
that minimize for energy, which is again
an approximation to the model evidence
so but, but it's important
to keep in mind the potential limitations
of this approach,
which is if you see here
this parameter space
it does look like
there is a kind of a nice single, right?
Like local minimum, right?
Local place
where the for energy is lowest or
where the again,
it would be at a local maximum
maybe like top of mountain in this
if you were talking about the
highest likelihood
they typically do
log likelihoods
as opposed to likelihoods.
And but one of the issues
is is this sort of
the parameter space need not have a
landscape that's quite this clean.
You might end up for instance
having a landscape
just moving to a two dimensional case.
Now that looks kind of like this
where if you start out say with a prior
value with prior values
that you know, like this kind of red
circle up here,
then if you do a gradient descent,
you might end up getting stuck
on a little local minimum like this
where you know, and then
and then the gradient descent algorithm
would say hey, you know, actually,
you know, this seems like the best one
because if I move in any direction,
then the free energy goes up
whereas
actually the global minimum,
the one that you would want to get to
is this different one
that's on the other side of this
little kind of free energy hill.
And so you know, this is
this is an example where
I'm choosing the right priors
as important
to get the to be able
to get the the best parameter estimates.
But also this speaks to the kind of thing
about parameter recovery
that I was talking about earlier,
because it could be that
if you set your parameters kind of right
on the top of this hill thing here,
then even if the parameter
combination over here
is the one that actually generated
the data,
you could get stuck over in this one,
in which case the estimation algorithm
would not give you the
right parameter estimates.
So this is
why what I mentioned earlier about
assessing parameter
recoverability is really important.
So although it's saying it's important
to choose good priors
or to figure out what good priors are
and there are there are interesting ways
to try to optimize that.
So there are kind of hierarchical
Bayesian techniques.
We don't talk about these explicitly,
but where you can kind of
and these won't necessarily
solve this problem, but where you can
more or less, you could think about it
as it estimates the parameters
for each person
and then it notices hey, you know,
looks like these are all shifted over.
You know,
the distribution of these looks like
they're all shifted over to the right,
you know, so
actually that looks like that
distribution is more kind of over here.
And so then it might
choose that
choose
that that the kind of mean value of that
as the new priors
or for redoing the estimates
until it finds values that
that essentially it's it's
helping you to find whatever
the optimal priors would be.
But again, that won't they won't always
solve this sort of problem
with that lumpy landscape.
You know.
One other little thought, it's actually
almost three layers with the red dot.
So there's us as agents on a landscape.
We actually need to come up with policy
as agents in our niche to get around
local minima, like my door is closed,
I need to step away to open the door
before I can move through it.
Then how are we going to fit policies
for ourself under pervasive uncertainty?
Well, we're doing this state estimation
with a policy C so that we can actually
then how are we going to converge
on those parameters
using a little bit like a gradient
descent algorithm internally
not internally sources,
just within the agents computationally.
It just it's a very interesting
because people may have
I'd imagine there's one
kind of person who sees this and says,
Oh, we talked about optimization
for a year in my course.
So I've heard all about non and convex,
non convex optimization techniques
or rugged fitness landscapes.
And there's another group of people for
whom actually this optimization theory
might be quite novel because of how
they've looked at modeling before.
So a very interesting
and to put into the fourth section like
that really spoke a lot.
So interesting stuff.
Right.
I just want to ask Christopher,
you want to add anything
before we continue with us?
No, this really is very much
Ryan's part of the paper.
Yeah, I'm just here if you.
Want more than a welcome to add thoughts
or if you have any other insights
about technical aspects.
No, no, nothing really.
I would just I might ask some questions
if something if things come up because
I'm going to be doing this at some point
in the next couple of months, but
so yeah.
Great.
That's
OK. So
so like I said, the kind of detailed
example that we are going to use
is variational base.
And note that variational message
crashing is again, what agents are using
within
within active inference models,
which we talked about before.
So now we're using something
very very similar to this
or I mean, so technically I should say
now it's using marginal message
passing in the latest versions.
But again, we cover this is very similar
to variational message passing.
It's just kind of a slight improvement,
but so we're using
the same sort of approach
to estimate parameters
personally to estimate the parameters
that people are using,
the parameters that are kind of,
you know, potentially kind of
stored in their brain in some sense
so so we're doing gradient descent
on Variational for energy,
as I mentioned, and as I mentioned,
need to specify prior means
and prior variances for each parameter
and then you just move the prior values
in the direction
of increasing action probabilities.
But what you're doing
because it's a gradient descent
on Variational for Energy is
you're not technically
just trying
to find the maximum likelihood value
like you're doing with like a grid search
instead what you're trying to do
is you're trying to well,
I should say that
the Variational for energy, part of it
means that there's a complexity penalty
and what that basically means is
so if people remember from Variational
for Energy when we talked about it
before, the simplest way or
kind of intuitive way to think about it
is that it's just complexity
minus accuracy.
Right?
And what complexity means is
how much you have to change your beliefs.
So if you start out with particular
prior values, then the farther
you have to move those move
your beliefs from those prior values,
the that's going to push
variational for energy up,
whereas at the same time
for Variational for Energy
is going to go down
as the model predicts behavior better.
So what it means is,
for instance, you know,
if I start out with a prior value
that say way down here, like around like,
I don't know, one in three,
then it's going to have to move
from those prior values.
A pretty long way before it gets to a set
of parameter values that fit well.
Whereas say, if I started over
here, it's
not going to have to move those as far.
But if I were to do that,
then potentially instead of
the posterior estimate
plus your parameter estimates
actually settling on this thing
that has the maximum likelihood
it might stop, say,
like around this one, right?
A little lower than it or
something like that.
Because that maximizes
that leads to high accuracy
while also not having to move
the parameter values really, really far,
not having to change beliefs too much
from what the
informed prior belief was.
So it's, you know, it's it's important,
right?
To think that this assumes
something that that the priors you have,
that you have them for a reason, right?
That they're actually based on something
they're informing you
so that so that is actually does
actually make sense
not to move them too
far from prior values.
And in practice,
the reason this is helpful
is because one thing that often happens
when you're just doing maximum likelihood
is that that maximum
likelihood will be with respect
to your particular data set, right.
Your particular set of parameter
or set of participants.
But often if you choose
just the maximum likelihood value
then that's kind of overfit
to just those participants
where if you were to say, apply
that exact same model
to a new set of participants,
it might not do as well
because it was fitting,
you know, specific things
that were not generalizable
about your data set in particular.
So by by,
by putting this kind of complexity
cost on it, it prevents overfitting,
which means that the predictions of that
model are more likely to generalize
to a new set of participants later,
so that it prevents overfitting,
which is a very common issue and just
standard frequentist statistics as well.
OK, so,
so that's so that's what you're doing.
A variational basis
is you're in this kind of complexity
minus accuracy thing where you're
preventing overfitting will also maximize
the accuracy of model predictions
OK, so then
like I mentioned, you need to do model
comparison to identify
what the best model is
now let's say.
So I just realized I should probably set
something in motion here
to see if I need to.
So when we actually go into the code
here in a minute,
one of these things takes a long time
let's say.
So I set it to store stuff.
I just want a triple check that
I shouldn't,
you know, set this thing
let's say.
Yeah, I about
I should double check this beforehand
yeah. So
cool though.
Really interesting.
And Christopher, you want to add anything
or maybe just a quick note?
Well, Ryan's figuring out like what is it
like to be learning these models
or what kind of skills do you wish
you had earlier
when you were learning the models
other than, of course, your own tutorial?
I mean,
I think everyone who did
undergrad psychology
is probably at some point in their I,
I did cognitive science as an undergrad,
but I took a lot of psychology classes.
I mean, take stuff psychology.
A lot of people read this Andy
Field textbook and he has a chapter on
some type of like
esoteric regression
and introductory sentences.
Like, I've never done this.
I don't see myself ever doing it,
but I wrote this chapter about it,
and if I ever need to do it,
I will be very impressed
by how much I seem to know.
So that may,
that probably will describe my experience
with this tutorial to a certain extent.
OK, so the results are real quick.
I'll just
I'm just going to jump to the code
and explain why
I should have started this. That
is. But
that so what if you set this thing to SIM
equals five,
then what it's going to do is it's going
to actually generate simulated behavior
for six hypothetical participants
where each participant
has a different combination
of parameter values that's generating
that simulated behavior.
And then what it's going to do
is it's going to
then apply the estimation algorithm
to the resulting simulated behavior
and it's
going to give you a set of results.
And then what it will do
is it's going to do a Bayesian model
comparison
on those to identify what the best model
is. And then I'm going to try to do this.
I'm going to try to set the
so I'll just say four or
for the purposes of, you know,
you actually
you guys are actually doing it
yourself at home.
I'm going to
I set this thing to 32 trials
for each simulate
for each set of simulated behavior.
But maybe if I set this to 16
then it will go faster.
Just to think about what's happening.
People looking through these equations
every time two matrices or two
numbers are getting multiplied
the computer has to do something.
So we're kind of nesting matrix
multiplications
inside of even bigger ones.
So if you want to time steps for two
larger time clicks for four models,
you know, for four participants,
it really starts to balloon rapidly,
especially when there's computationally
intensive steps.
Yeah.
So here just to
just to show you guys what's going
on, so I just started this thing
and if you look in the MATLAB window
here, it's calculating log likelihood.
So LX stands for log likelihood
over and over again under a particular
set of parameter values.
And in this case, it's -31
and it's trying to minimize that.
Or in this case, it's
moving it closer to zero.
So maximizing in a sense,
but bring it in closer to zero.
So now it move to a gradient descent
to a second set of parameter values
and now it's found that OK,
now the log likelihood is -22.
So we're even closer to zero.
And again, same thing now we're in -19
and it's going to keep going
until it settles on a stable value.
And in this graph
that will update every time,
which I'll show you here.
So this is just showing
ignore, I should say these.
So let me to explain as these routines
were originally designed
for DCM for dynamic causal
modeling with a primary.
So a lot of the bunch of these graphs
and also
the sorts of labels that they have
are don't really apply in this case.
They only apply to DCM.
So, you know,
so ignore all of the labels.
But the point here is, is that
each iteration as you go from left
to right, is a new estimate
of the log likelihood
for every
for the set of parameter values.
It's trying during gradient descent.
And so you'll see that after a while.
The thing is just going to kind of
play out, it'll converge onto a value.
So right now is it's like 17.35
and now it's like 17.16.
So the thing is kind of starting
to converge on a stable
minimum
log likelihood.
So now, you know, I found a site
that actually is still at 16.
So the thing is still going for a bit
to converge
and down here
these are the posterior deviations.
I'm going again, ignore the ignore
a lot of the units here,
but the way that you can read
this is just that zero here
corresponds to the prior values
that you set.
And if it's going
if the bar here is going down, then
that means that the posterior parameter
estimate is, is lower at this point.
It's gone down from the prior value
and this kind of red
pink thing around it,
that's the posterior variance.
So in this case and parameter
one here is the action precision
and parameter
two is the reward area for risk seeking.
I think I can double check
whether those are backwards or not.
But which part of those are.
But this is just saying that
whatever the first parameter is,
the, the posterior
mean estimate here is you know,
whatever that is that
actually corresponds to the real units
of the M of the parameter.
But it's not very confident
in that posterior mean estimate.
Whereas here the second parameter,
it's also this negative posterior
at the moment,
but it's very,
very confident in that post.
Your estimate
so so that's what that means.
And these will update
with each iteration.
But so now you can see that
actually the thing kept exploring
and now it's actually found
a set of parameter values that,
you know, continues
to actually explain the behavior
the simulated behavior
quite a bit better. Right?
So now it's at like -13.
So you can see this
ad almost kind of converge for a bit,
but now it's actually
kind of going back up
so eventually, eventually
it will converge, but it's just doing
really, really well at finding values
that explain behavior well.
One thing I should point out, though,
is that the actual values of these
the absolute value of these
are not really informative
because they're
they're they're basically the sums
of the action
probabilities for each trial.
So these numbers will be bigger
if the task has more trials.
So in and of themselves, it's only
the relative values that are meaningful.
This reminds me, I guess it reminds me
a lot of Bayesian methods
in follow genetics
where it's like, what is the likelihood
of this phylogenetic tree?
It's given some number by a program,
which sounds weird to think about
the state space of all the possible trees
or something like that.
But it turns out by doing this
kind of a gradient descent,
searching through all the possible trees,
you actually do converge on a tree
that is generative of the kinds of data
that are observed
and so it's just really interesting
to see how this is working,
and it's fun to watch
the number drop down too.
So, so
now so in this case, it converged
for the first person
and these were the posterior deviations.
And then here's the simulated behavior
of the participant
under those parameters.
So you can see that the parameters do
the behavior really well, right?
The probabilities are pretty high
under those parameters
for each for every action.
There are some little exceptions,
but but it does pretty well
right now.
It's just the it's
just moving on to the next person.
Sorry. Well.
It might just be helpful to describe
what the blue dots are this year.
Yeah, sorry.
I guess I'm assuming people
have watched the sessions.
So blue corresponds
to the actual chosen action
on the
at the first action for each participant.
So basically, this is saying
and so black means probability one.
And as it goes toward white,
that means probability zero.
So this is just saying basically 100%
probability under the model
that the agent would choose the hint
and the blue dot says
that's what they actually trials
and so on and so forth.
So any time that there's a light gray
you know,
that's on the part where the blue dot is,
that means the model
didn't really do that
well at predicting that behavior.
But you can see in this case
most it's pretty dark around
most of these blue dots.
So it does pretty good is the point.
So now like I said,
this is just going to iterate around
for the six agents that I mentioned
and it's just going to compare
and then it's going to compare the three,
the three that did have a learning rate
and the three that didn't have a learning
rate in the model is what it will do.
And so just to kind of summarize
what you said so far,
so the steps would be
something like you would actually
get your empirical task right
and think about how the sub the
the actions that the subject is actually
got all the participants actually going
to make relate to what the model is going
to make all the actions available.
The model, you come up with some mapping
and then you would then
presumably in this just translate them
in some way and plug those into your
you mdpd out you, which is the actions
participant chose and mdpd
which is the observations
that they actually saw.
Yeah.
And then you would
plug into the algorithm essentially. Yep.
You plug it into the algorithm and,
and then adjust
the algorithm just repeatedly computes
the sum of the log likelihoods
for each trial
and then and then tries to find a minimum
of that some.
OK and so in terms of
this is a something I've wondered about,
how do you choose what the best
trials are, what the best surprise
is, OK, just to kind of in silicone
simulate a bunch of things and just
say, hey, this, this seems reasonable.
In order and a lot of cases. Yes.
I mean,
so there's a couple of things to do.
One is you can
you can do the kind of model
after the recoverability stuff
you know, beforehand
and try to find a set of parameter
values, a set of prior values
for which the
the the parameter
estimates are recoverable.
Right.
So if you set one set of priors,
then maybe the thing does
get stuck in a local minima.
But if you have another set of priors,
then the generative parameters
actually do end up matching
the estimated parameters really well.
Yeah.
So, so there's
there's a couple of different things.
So one is, yeah,
do some of the simulation recoverability
stuff ahead of time to find good priors.
And another thing is, you know,
if you just,
you know, estimate participant behavior
and you start to see
that the posterior estimates tend
to be really far away from the priors,
you're setting
that that's kind of an indication
that you're probably
not setting very good priors.
So then you might like
try setting new priors that look closer
to where everybody's kind of moving.
Yeah.
So we do have we do have a footnote
about this in the paper from memory,
but be good to kind of make
that explicit.
Another way that I've seen that
in the field of evolutionary biology is
if you have wildly disparate priors,
like so a fallacy
is that the uniform
or the flat prior is like unbiased.
There's so much to say about that
I'm sure Ryan knows well.
But like if you have one prior
that stacked up against zero
and another prior
that stacked up against one,
and then they both converge
like from kind of multiple sides.
That's a simple example, but two
different families of priors and models
that are very pared down, ranging to ones
that have very complex error models.
If a lot of different layers
of complexity of the model and densities
that start stacked up versus one
end versus another, then of course
that's a difficult thing to manage.
But that at least means
that given the empirical data you have
and the task that you're modeling,
you have a really predictive model.
So again, we're not realists,
we're not actually getting at the truth
with these recursive and iterative
and multi perspectively models.
We're just fitting more and more of the
variance explained in our empirical data
yeah.
Yeah.
So just just
to kind of give you guys another example.
So you can see now for this
other set of parameter estimates,
you know, convergence took way
less time right?
It just took, you know, seven iterations
and it converges really quickly.
And one reason to see why is, is that
for this one, it doesn't have to move
values very far from priors
because this was an agent
whose behavior was generated
by parameters very close to priors.
One other point to those,
even if it looks flat for ten time steps,
it could still be trapped,
which is why things have to be seeded
and have really good randomness,
because there's no hard and fast rule
for when you terminate.
So, for example,
in a lot of the evolutionary simulations,
we would do you discard the first
like 10,000 or more timestamps,
like burn in, you just discard them
because you think that actually it's
too much reflecting your prior estimates.
And then even if it looks like it's
converging or as one of my professors
called it, a fuzzy caterpillar
because it's
kind of like the model of sampling
from the fullest possible
range of variables.
And it was still coming back home.
That's the fuzzy caterpillar.
But even then
it could look like a fuzzy caterpillar
for like a lot of time steps
and then just totally hit on a new
combination break into a new realm.
So it's really hard. And it just.
So, just so people know
that's actually not true in this case.
So a variational basis
is deterministic in the sense that you
you don't do this kind of,
you know, burden.
You don't write a sorry variability.
You just deterministic.
Like, if I ran this over and over again,
it would give me the exact same
parameter estimate each time.
So there is there is actually no variable
I mean, the kind of thing you're
talking about is more like Monte Carlo.
And it's going to say sort of approaches.
Yeah, sorry.
I didn't mean to say that
there was a burden.
I agree.
That was just.
Yeah, little analogy,
but thanks for clarifying.
So one advantage of Monte
Carlo sampling methods is that you over
given infinite time, you're guaranteed
to margin to approach the true posterior
or to obtain the true posterior it's
also extremely computationally expensive.
Variational Bayes is really quick.
Yeah.
Like you can run this stuff
on your laptop.
So the Monte Carlo is based
upon sampling.
That was the different domain
that I was referencing there.
You have to sample in cases
where you don't know
some of these distributions
don't have them defined.
So perfectly, but when you have access
to this level of specifying,
then there's
a whole new range of techniques,
which is why
it looks more like matrix multiplication.
And this sort of like convergence
to the variational free energy estimate
rather than just sampling endlessly
from a landscape that's unknown,
you know, anything else.
But yeah, thanks for that. Sorry.
So, so just take I mean,
so again, just to give you guys a sense,
so in this so this kind of participant,
you can see that it's pretty kind of
the distributions are a lot less precise.
And this is a person who has a much lower
action precision value.
So these were generated by a lower action
precision value agent
and the model is doing a pretty good job
just finding a low action
precision value that kind of spreads
the distributions flat enough around it
that it captures it provides
decent evidence for each action.
And so anyway, so just,
just to again, to,
to give you guys an intuition
for what's going on
but so once this is done,
then what will happen is we'll have these
the free energies of the winning model
for each person,
for each of the two models,
the one with
and the one without learning rate.
And so we want to do is
we want to do Bayesian model comparison,
which is where you're going to compare
the free energies
for each model, for each participant
to find the model with the lowest
free energy across participants
and the winning model.
So the the little spin function
that we include here,
it'll spit out several things
but the one that you want to focus on
just to keep things simple is
the one that has the highest what's
called the protected exceeds probability
and this is just the probability
that each model is the most likely model
across all subjects
while taking into account the null
possibility, the differences in model
evidence are did a chance.
So so it's like I said, it's
just it's just which is the best model
when taking into account
the null model as a possibility.
And I'll
show you that
in a second, let's say, is this thing
that's still going it's.
Yeah, OK, so on.
Hopefully it'll be done soon.
But so I'll keep
I'll keep moving through here
and then we can return to this once
it's done
it's actually gone pretty fast
since I made it.
So a few trials,
but so now so that's
what we're doing here.
And so now,
you know, we've
kind of already touched on this a bit,
but so now is the point
where we would confirm
that the best model is identifiable
or that the parameters are recoverable
and this is already mentioned this
a little bit.
But that, you know, it's,
it's clear that not all models
are necessarily going to have unique
parameter solutions, right?
So if you have a landscape like this,
you might start out priors
at very similar places
and gradient
descent would lead you to minima
different minima, you know, different
combinations of parameter values.
That are equally good
at reproducing a participant's behavior.
So so you always have to show
that whatever model you're using
and the priors that you're using
will give you the same parameters that
you fit in to generate
the data to begin with.
And so here again, we talked about this
a little bit, but step one is
you would specify multiple
sets of generative parameter values
which is what we're doing.
And this is important
as you should select values
that are the same or similar
to the actual parameter combinations
that you got in your
in your true participants,
because it can be the case that parameter
estimates are totally recoverable
for a certain parameter combinations,
but are not recoverable
for other parameter combinations.
So you care about the ones you're
actually getting for your participants.
So then you want to simulate behavior.
So generate simulated behavior
using each of those parameter
value combinations, run
that simulated behavior
through the estimation routine
just like you would for real data.
And then check
whether the generative parameters
and the estimated parameters
are highly correlated
so when I run this in advance,
you know, so without having to run it in
real time, like I'm doing right now,
then for this particular case
and bear in mind
this is one I'm using 32 trials,
not like the 16 or whatever I put in now
just to make things go faster
this is what I get for it,
for Alpha, for action, precision,
for the two parameter model.
So you can see even with only six people,
the correlation between the generative
action precision and the estimated
extra precision is pretty good. .81.
So even with six people,
right, it's significant
whereas for
I only have well anyway, I have,
I have a bunch of them.
I can, I can, I can pull
I can probably pull them up
let's see.
That's for a different thing.
Oh, that was very true.
Interesting.
Yes. Sorry.
I'm just trying to find
trying to find the figures
that I have probably here
well,
no, OK, it's not positive
work with them actually.
But if I can't find them here, then
it will, it will spit them out.
But, but point by point being, these are
in this case, even with the six values,
all of the parameters
tend to be really good.
Right.
In terms of recoverability, the,
you know,
the correlations between generative
and estimated parameters tend to be know
between point seven and 1.7 and point
nine something or other.
So there they're, they're good.
And so then so then finally,
the last thing that we want to do is once
we have
parameter estimates for each person
in a winning model that is recoverable,
then we can take those values
and we can put those parameter,
we can use those parameters
as individual difference measures
between subjects, you know.
And at that point, there's
a number of things that you can do.
So, you know, the kind of simple thing,
you know, if you if you want to kind of
fall back on, on frequentist statistics
is, you know, you can do standard tests.
ANOVA is correlations, regressions,
et cetera.
And then, you know,
I mean, you know, we've done that before.
It's fine in some cases
if you want to kind of stick
with the more kind of general Bayesian
theme of active inference,
then you can also do things like,
you know, do things
more like base factor analyzes
and you know,
both of these are often kind of used
or even used together.
And just to give you a couple examples,
I'm just going to triple check
that this thing is not done yet.
Still not done.
Just one note.
There's the SBM textbook
has many points of contact
between parametric and like standard
very classical statistical approaches
and then very Bayesian approaches
and mixed methods and it will switch out
or show it both ways.
So it really is pretty interesting
how it comes together here.
So so to kind of show
you guys a couple of examples
of how you would use
these kind of, you know, use parameters
at the group level.
And this is just I'll give you
a couple examples from from our papers
so in this in this one in Journal of
Psychiatry and Neuroscience,
what we did is we had
this simple kind of approach,
avoidance, conflict task, where
more or less the participant
had to kind of choose to move
this little avatar guy closer, farther
from one of these two ends
of this little kind of run away thing.
And they knew that
the closer they were to one side,
the higher the probability was that
they would get an outcome associated
with symbols on the left side.
And same goes
the closer are to the right,
the higher probability
of getting the outcomes
associated with the right side.
And here, rain cloud means
they heard like a really aversive sound
and saw like a really aversive picture.
You know, like it's like hearing girl
screaming and seeing a picture of her
being like pulled into a van,
you know, like really negative stuff.
And whereas
a something here and you kind of saw
this kind of like neutral,
maybe slightly happy thing
and you had this kind of red,
this kind of bar thing on the side.
And the more filled the red bar was,
the more points they would win.
So you have kind of clear cases, right?
Where it's
just if it's just rain cloud versus sun,
you should just go to the right.
If it's just sun and sun
plus some reward,
you should want to go to the right.
And then you have these conflict cases
where it's negative stuff.
Plus you get some reward negative stuff,
but you get it, plus you get even more
reward and negative stuff
and even more than that.
And so
and so that's how the task is structured.
And so you can make
a pretty simple model of this
where one state factor
is beliefs about the trial type.
Right. Whether it's
this kind of trial, this kind of trial,
this kind of trial, this control
or that kind of trial
and then you can have a state factor
corresponding to beliefs
about the runaway position, right?
So beliefs
about whether the avatar is in position
one, two, three, or four
or five et cetera.
That's it.
And then you just have you set up
likelihoods that generate the probability
of of each position
generating what sorts of outcomes
and what sorts of runaway
positions given beliefs about trial type
testimony here.
Right.
So you have it phrased
as they're being five trial types,
but would it be possible
to have like a model
where it was like a state estimate left
in a state estimate, right.
For the stimuli type and a state
estimate left and state estimate
right for the reward value,
because this frames it in
a very behavioral trial
centric way with doing estimate on
which one of the five scenarios are in.
But I'm just trying to think about cases
where you might not know
which scenario you're in or even what
the total set of scenarios is.
So you're just doing state
estimate on reward and on stimuli
yeah.
I mean, I mean, yes, I mean the well,
well, I guess it kind of depends, right?
So I mean, if you
if you were to give somebody sort
of uncertain cues about trial type
then, then I mean, presumably
you would just you would need to
I mean, you would just still have
if they know what the different trial
type possibilities are,
then you could just have uncertain cues.
They just don't have a precise belief
with that precise prior
belief over the different
over this state factor.
But if you didn't
if there wasn't any set beliefs
about trial types and there's just
any possible combination of,
you know, sun clouds, zero
points, two, four and six, then
I suppose you could do something
where you just have a kind of non factor.
I a state factor that has like
just every possible combination
or something like that.
You could do that. I mean, it would and.
There are reasons to actually build like
so there are
obviously time saving and model building
considerations that mean
you should use factor as distributions
but they're actual empirical
considerations, which means that I think
if you want to build a model, that's kind
of realistically how the brain works.
You should tend towards
in a lot of cases, you should tend
towards factories distributions.
So for example, there's good evidence
that there's a size representation
of task phase in PFC
and MTL is pretty good evidence.
So I mean the what versus where
streams and vision
that's a factor sized representation
so very.
Yeah.
So you're kind of using it in
like a course screening sense
to say
sometimes you don't want to even allow
for the all by all,
because it's more categorical
how the task is being modeled anywhere
like fight or flight.
You would want to have all combinations
of elbow and the movements.
You're fitting something that's kind of
at the wrong dimensionality.
And so for a lot of reasons,
not the least of which it seems like
that's what organisms would
do, would be at that high
dimensional manifold
or the factory's representation.
Yeah, well, and, and in this case, right.
I mean, just we have experimental
the experimental design is such
that they are they do know
ahead of time what the different possible
combinations are, right?
So I mean, they just they just already
know that there are these combinations
so it's it's
consistent with their beliefs
about the generative model that we have
given them via the instructions.
So and
so so in this case,
you know, we had a pretty typical,
you know, sort of sort of model,
graphical model with two parameters.
We had our beta here, which corresponds
to the expected for energy precision
here,
you know, just to be intuitive
for the clinical audience.
And we were going for
we just called this decision uncertainty.
And then we had a
and so that's just
this is again, this is the rate prior
or rate parameter
for a gamma distribution over
or this gamma term
and which again is a
a thing
that modulates the expected free energy
estimate over policies
so modulates this thing.
But then the other parameter we had
was this emotion conflict parameter,
which just said basically
how much they dislike
the negative stimulus, how how aversive
they expect the negative stimulus to be
and so you can kind of show
and simulation.
So each one of these
vertical bars here corresponds to beliefs
about what state
you are in on the runway.
So if theta equals one and the
and the emotion conflict equals one,
then you should expect that
if the good thing is on the it is OK.
And this is a
this is a conflict plus two points trial.
So basically
the thing will approach the reward,
even if it's going to see something
negative of this year's one
and it will do it deterministically
whereas if x three,
then it will fairly deterministically
choose to go away from the negative
stimulus even if they would get reward
whereas if they have higher,
higher values,
so more decision uncertainty, then
this distribution becomes they become
a lot less confident in this distribution
and in choosing these kinds of values
that are more like in the middle
and and the likelihood is
is pretty clear just in each trial type,
each of the different
each column
here is a different runaway position.
They will just generate the negative
stimulus with an increasing probability
as it goes left and the positive stimulus
with an increasing probability
as it goes right.
ET cetera.
The only confusing thing here is,
is that white means higher probability
in these, whereas black
it means higher probability here. But
but anyway, so that's that's it.
And just kind of et cetera, et cetera,
for the five trial types.
So in this case, what we found was
if you look at healthy control,
us versus people with depression
and anxiety versus people of substance
use disorders,
the emotion
conflict is actually interestingly higher
in healthy and lowest in substance
use disorder, whereas decision
uncertainty is highest
in substance use disorder
and kind of medium and depression,
anxiety and low and healthy controls.
And these are significantly different.
And that's true in a propensity
matched, propensity matched sample.
And at a larger sample.
So it's interesting thing
where it might be more of a
what might be more clinically relevant
as this kind of uncertainty over options
as opposed to just being more sensitive
to negative stimuli.
Right.
How would a. Second.
How would that shape just kind of curious
if it doesn't have a
if it's not known, but how would that
shape treatment or conversation
or approach in a given situation
from whichever role makes sense?
Like to say, oh, it's not actually
this psychological construct,
but it's actually related
to something like this.
I mean, in terms of like informing
treatment or something like that.
Sure.
Like treatment via any modality
yeah.
I mean, so I mean, typically the
the main sorts of things
you might want to do
is, you know, either talking about
so say, you know, baseline
before somebody starts treatment
what their beta value was, right?
It might be the case
you'd have to study to show this, but
it might be the case that given different
beta values at baseline,
you know, like people with high
beta values might respond well to CBT
cognitive behavioral therapy,
whereas people with low better values
might respond
better to act or might respond
better to an SSRI or,
you know, like something like that.
So either it's either it's something
I mean, that's kind of the ideal
thing is you want to say,
can I get this information?
And it will give me information
about how to treat a person
but there are there are lots of
other things you might do besides that.
But that's, that's like a primary kind
of, you know, like ultimate goal example.
Yeah.
It's, it's interesting how there's
probably a lot to be said and learned
about the actual application
of active inference clinically.
But even here on the beginning
of applying it
we can use it
as just a potential biomarker,
just like a summary statistic
related to a questionnaire
or some other thing that's estimated
from empirical clinical data
fitting a different kind of underlying
generative model.
So instead of doing a regression,
oh, people who have higher on this
end up doing better or worse
in this kind of a program.
Well, now we can just do that
same kind of parameter
testing in the context
of a different type of model.
It's an active inference
generative model.
So I think that those are just
some points of contact,
but it's really interesting stuff.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, you can do lots of other
interesting things with these, right?
So this this beta parameter,
if you remember from previous sessions,
is what's associated with
it's proposed
to be associated with dopamine
dynamics in the brain.
And I'll show you briefly a study,
an example study later,
which we're fill up short and back,
like I mentioned before,
actually showed that
the trial by trial updates in beta
that are predicted by
the model were correlated with
both signal and F MRI
in in the midbrain in a midbrain
region that's associated with dopamine.
So whereas
whereas the way that we're doing this
here, we just have a stable
beta estimate for each person.
But you might look at
say, individual differences between
contrast values in an F MRI analysis
at the group level, you know,
so like people with higher
beta values have higher say
basal ganglia responses
to reward versus
no reward or something like that.
So you could do that
kind of thing as well.
So both both individual
level and group level
F MRI sorts of approaches
as well as much fancier things
but those are just
two kind of simple examples.
So as a, as another example of doing this
in the domain of perception
and sort of decision making,
you know, we we used this
in the context of a task where a person
is just told to push a button
every time they feel their heartbeat
and so in this model,
we don't even have like an explicit
policy selection part.
All we do is
they start with a precise belief
that they're
in this start state at Time one,
and then they have prior beliefs
about whether or not
they're going to transition into a state
of feeling their heartbeat versus not.
So probability of no heartbeat,
probably a heartbeat.
And those priors are encoded
in this in the B matrix here.
The transition matrix
where sort of the higher the B is,
the more they expect to feel a heartbeat,
you know, more often.
Right, on each trial.
And and
then also there's a precision value here
which corresponds to beliefs
about how precise the actual afferent
signal is coming up from the heart.
And so we can estimate this IPI
parameter is intercept of precision
and this prior of heartbeats,
I should say.
We also compared this to a model
that included learning in this task
and in this case, the model,
including learning, didn't win
and so what we found here
is and I should say
also that they do this task three times.
They do it once when they're told
they're allowed to guess once
and they're told
they're not allowed to guess
and only to press it
when they're sure they felt something.
And one where aside from in addition
to no guessing,
they're told to hold their breath,
which kind of makes it on average easier
to feel your heartbeat
and so it kind of
amplifies the afferent signal,
makes it more precise.
What we found was that in healthy people,
the breath hold
actually amplified
into receptive precision a lot.
Whereas in all the clinical groups,
anxiety, depression, co-morbid
depression, anxiety, eating disorders
and substance use disorders,
they just stayed flat, low interceptor
precision values
so that the actual changing, the
actual precision of the afferent signal
didn't have any effect on their beliefs.
About the precision of the signal.
Yeah.
So something like a like a rigidity
in the way that the brain treats afferent
intercepted signals and psychiatric
disorders trance diagnostically.
And so again,
this is just a again, kind of a standard
like mixed model sort of analysis.
Whereas if you compare, say,
estimates
for prior expectations, everybody
showed higher
prior values and the guessing condition
than in the other two conditions.
Which you would expect.
But there were no differences
between healthy and clinical groups.
So it's kind of interesting.
It says, hey,
maybe this is more a precision
issue than it is a prior expectation.
Issue in terms of clinical significance.
Or bias
or another task has to be explored.
I mean.
If I put in a plug,
I'll call that people as I mean, Faisal
being a lot of conceptual work on
interception and active inference,
and there's been a lot of discussion
about whether it's priors or precision
or anything like that,
and to my knowledge, I'm happy
to be corrected about this by Ryan,
but that was the first time
that it's really been tested empirically.
Right
yes or no?
There's no there's no other
there's no other like actual formal
fitting models to data studies
that I've tried that before.
So epic work. There.
There are there are papers
that have tested like more kind of like
quote unquote qualitative
or just kind of like go up versus down
sorts of predictions
that fall out of computational models,
but not actually fitting a model. Yes.
This is the first model
based analysis of this kind of thing.
Right.
Yeah. And we've and it's cool.
We've actually replicated the results in
healthy controls in a second sample now.
So it seems like they effect at least
the effect on health is is pretty robust.
We haven't been able to replicate
we haven't tried to replicate the
the lack of of an effect
in clinical populations yet.
But that's kind of in the works
cool.
So so so anyway, so this continues
this continues to go here,
but it should be
I think it should be almost done
pretty quick it's only took six people
surprised.
An interception question
and then one question from the chat
so what other intercept of methodologies
might exist.
So you did a heart rate estimation task.
What other intercepted
modalities might be amenable
to this kind of quantitative analysis?
So definitely,
definitely cardiac interception tasks are
our most common
just because it's it's
actually quite difficult.
The methodologies
is it's pretty difficult to use.
So for instance, envision, right?
You can like very tightly control
or in audition
you can really tightly control
the timing and magnitude.